SAILOR ABOARD THAT SHIP
DEMANDING ANSWERS ABOUT HIS SON.
ALEX MARQUADT.
>> Reporter: QUESTIONS REMAINED
OF HUNDREDS OF SAILORS, OF THICK
SMOKE BELLOWED FROM THE SHIP
BEFORE IT SANK.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAID AN
AMERICAN OFFICIAL BELIEVED TO BE
TRUE OF THE DAMAGE DONE BY
UKRAINIANS.
>> THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS
HIDING VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE MOSKVA THAT IT WAS
ATTACKED BY THE UKRAINIANS AND
IT WAS ATTACK BY MISSILES AND
DEATHS THE CASUALTY TOTALS RIGHT
NOW.
IT IS A REALLY DISSERVICE TO THE
RUSSIAN POPULATION.
>> Reporter: THE SURVIVING
SAILORS WERE BROUGHT TO CRIMEA
WHERE CIVILIANS LAID FLOWERS AND
WREATHS AND ADMISSION OF THERE
WERE INDEED LOSSES DESPITE
RUSSIA'S CLAIM THAT EVERYONE GOT
OFF THE SHIP.
>> THERE WILL BE VICTORIES AND
LOSSES.
>> Reporter: THE INITIAL LINE
WAS THERE WERE NO UKRAINIAN
ATTACK BUT INSTEAD THERE WAS A
FIRE ON BOARD WHICH CAUSED THE
EXPLOSION.
IT IS A HUMILIING LOSS FOR
RUSSIA BUT A DEVASTATING ONES
FOR THE PARENTS OF THE SAILORS
KILLED.
THE FATHER OF A YOUNG CONSCRIPT
WRITING ON SOCIAL MEDIA, A
TRAGEDY OCCURRED, THE TRUTH
ABOUT WHICH WE HAVE NOT YET
FOUND OUT.
THE STORY THEY ARE GETTING A
LIE, DMITRY SHKREBETS WRITES.
THERE IS NO INFORMATION.
A SECOND MOTHER WHO SAYS SHE WAS
TOLD HER SON WAS DEAD AND TOLD
THE BBC SHE BELIEVES DOZENS ARE
STILL UNACCOUNTED FOR.
>> AND KATE, WESTERN COUNTRIES
ARE HOPING RUSSIAN FAMILIES
TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON
IN UKRAINE THAT THEY'LL PROTEST
OR PUT PRESSURE ON THE PUTIN'S
REGIME TO END THIS WAR.
I SAW THAT DIRECT EFFORT WHEN I
WAS IN UKRAINE.
UKRAINIANS SET UP A HOTLINE FOR
RUSSIAN FAMILIES TO CALL TO FIND
OUT INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS IF THEY HAVE
BEEN KILLED OR WOUNDED